مشاهدينا اعتقل عملاء مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي الشخص المشتبه به في تسريب
وثائق البانتاجون ونشرت وسائل اعلام
امريكيه لحظه اعتقال المشتبه به في مدينه
دايتون بولايه ماستا الذي اشار تقرير
لنيويورك تايمز الى انه يدعى جاك تكسيرا
وانه مجند في سلاح الجو بالحرس الوطني
واعلن البنتاجون ان التحقيقات لا تزال
مستمره بشان مسرب الوثائق السريه حول ما
اثير عن وسائل الاعلام عن محتوى تلك
الوثائق
ون ياخذ موضوع تسريبات الوثائق على محمل
الجد وصلنا العمل الاستخباراتي على مدار
الساعه لكشف ملابسات الامر وكيفيه سير
التحقيق بشان مسرب الوثائق السريه وماذا
سنتحدث عن الوثائق المسرب الحساسه على
خاصه ما اثر عبر وسائل الاعلام عن محتوى
تلك الوثائق
اذا مشاهدينا وزير العدل الامريكي الان
يتحدث عن توجيه تهم افشاء السريه عن وثائق
البنتاجون للمشتبه فيه جاك تكسيرا كان
ايضا تحدث وزير العدل عن انه
المشتبه به سيحقق معه في محكمه بوسطن
ونشاهد هذه الصور للحظه اعتقال الشاب جاك
المشتبه به بتسريب وثائق البنتاجون طبعا
مكتب التحقيقات هو من اعتقل المشتبه به
وهذه الصور التي نشاهدها للشاب الذي يبلغ
من العمر 21 عاما
ينضم الينا حسين الطوط مراسل العربيه حسين
يعني تم القاء القبض على المشتبه به جاك
الشاب جاك يعني من خلال
الخطاب الذي استمعنا اليه منذ قليل
للمتحدث باسم البنتاجون ما الذي يمكن يعني
التعليق عليه
تحيه لك راويه قبل قليل كان وزير العدل
يتحدث وقال بانه سيتم التحقيق مع جاكيت
تشارل في ولايه مساجسيت قبل ان يؤتى به
الى هنا على واشنطن كما كانت وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه تقول سيتم تحقيق معه في
محكمه فيدراليه في ولايه
ايضا قال بانه سيتم توجيه تهم افشاء
السريه عن وثائقون لهذا الشاب بالنسبه
للبنتاجون طبعا يعتبر ان ما جرى هو عملا
اجراميا متعمدا افشاء هذه الوثائق
وتسريبها اعتبرها عمل اجرامي متعمد قال
ايضا بانه سيبحث بكيفيه حمايه هذه الوثائق
وتوزيعها وايضا وضع اجراءات جديده لعدم
حدوث هكذا تسريبات في المستقبل الموضوع
يتفاعل بشكل سريع ما جرى بالفعل شكل
صدمه للكثيرين خاصه انه ياتي بعد نحو 10
سنوات من وثائق ويكيليكس والاجراءات
والبروتوكولات التي وضعت في الباندا وفي
مراكز حساسه امريكيه وغيرها لكي يتم تجنب
وقوع تسريبات اخرى والان ياتي هذا الشاب
الذي يبلغ من العمر 21 عاما ويحصل على
ويكون سيستطيع الوصول الى هكذا وسائل وهذا
يضع تساؤلات كبيره كيف يمكنه ان يحصل على
هكذا تصريح ليصل الى هكذا وثائق سئل
المتحدث باسم الفانتاغون طبعا حاول تجنب
الاجابه بطريقه ما
واوضح بان من يحصل على هذا التصريح يكون
على حسب التقييم حاجه هذا الشخص كمسؤول
لكي يحصل عليه ولكن هناك تساؤلات بان هذا
الشاب حديث السن 21 عاما عاده المسؤولين
الذين يحصلون على كذا تصريحات يكون لديهم
سنوات في الخدمه ان كان في المخابرات او
في مراكز اخرى لكي يكون لديهما كذا
تصريحات هناك اسئله كثيره تطرح الان
الاجابه عنها ستاتي تباعا من خلال
التحقيقات مع هذا الشاب
يركز على التحقيق حول كيفيه التسريب فيما
طبعا وزاره العدل لديها تحقيقات جنائيه
وستوجه له تهم جنائيه هذا ما فهمنا حتى
الان
راويه نعم ومعي في هذه التغطيه من واشنطن
وليد فارس وايضا ايهاب عباس المحللين
السياسيين المتخصصين بالشان الامريكي سيد
سيد وليد يعني هل القاء القبض على هذا
الشاب المشتبه به بتسريب وثائق البانتاجون
يعني تكشف كم كبير من المعلومات التي سربت
يبدو ان السيد وليد ليس معي سيد ايهاب
نعم تفضلي حضرتك نعم سيدي ايهاب يعني كنت
اسال عن مجرد القاء القبض على المشتبه به
هل يعني بانه العديد من المعلومات كم هائل
من المعلومات قد يعرف منه هل ينتمي يعني
الى مجموعات خارجيه ربما ام انه يعمل
بمفرده
نعم بكل تاكيد ستكون هناك تحقيقات
المعلومات كثيره جدا اعتقد ال 24 ساعه
القادمه يعني سيكون هناك معلومات كثيره
ربما لن تكشف عنها حتى
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه او وزاره العدل
وهو معنيتان بهذه التحقيقات مباشره سيكون
هناك تروي كثير
قبل ان يتم نشر المعلومات والبيانات كلها
لوسائل الاعلام بكل تاكيد وسائل الاعلام
شغوفه لمعرفه تفاصيل وايضا المواطنين
الامريكيين وكل من هو معني بهذا الامر
سيتم اعطائهم الكثير من المعلومات لكن
اعتقد ان المعلومات الحساسه جدا سيتم
الاحتفاظ بها لاكثر وقت ممكن حتى يتم
التاكد من مدى صحتها ومدى فعاليتها ومدى
خطورتها على المجتمع الامريكي وعلى علاقات
امريكا بالدول التي اتى على ذكرها او اتت
على ذكرها هذه التسريبات بكل تاكيد هذا
الشاب الصغير
سيكون مسارا للجدل داخل المتحده الامريكيه
خاصه اذا ما جاءت تحقيقات لتركيب انتمائه
لاي ربما من الحركات اليمينيه داخل
المجتمع الامريكي او المعارضه للحرفي
اوكرانيا او اذا كانت له علاقات
بالخارج يعني يعمل لمصلحه دوله ما من خلال
الم
علومات الا تجرى له يعني فحوصات لمعرفه ان
كان يعاني من اضطراب النفسي ام لا ام انه
لديه ارتباط بجهات خارجيه او يعني طيار
معين قد يكون ضد سياسه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالداخل او الخارج
يعني شوفوا حضرتك هو طبعا لا يوجد
عاده اشخاص
يكونون سالمين عقليا 100%
او انهم ليس من الممكن ان يتغيروا فيما
يتعلق بصحتهم العقليه او بانتمياتهم
سياسيه او مجتمعيه او تنظيميه يعني هناك
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سمعنا
كثيرا وشاهدنا طبعا جنود في الجيش
الامريكي قاموا بقتله اصدقائهم وزملائهم
في معسكرات مختلفه
شاهدنا اعتداءات ايضا باشكال مختلفه من
قبل
منتمين لاجهزه انفاذ الشرطه والقانون في
الولايات المتحده والجيش كذلك فبالتالي
تغيير الرؤيه والفكره من الممكن ان تحدث
والتجنيد من الممكن يحدث والتجميد في عالم
التجسس قائم ويحدث لكن لا اريد ان اقصد
على النتائج وعلى الحقائق فقط ما لدينا
اليوم هو ان هذا الشخص صغير السن ويعمل في
الجيش الامريكي او كان يعمل في الجيش
الامريكي واتته الفرصه للاطلاع على مثل
هذه الملفات الحساسه جدا ذات الاهميه
الكبيره
واستغلها بصوره سيئه اليوم المشكله هل هذا
الاستغلال كان بناء على طلب من جهات
الخارجيه دول معاديه دول منافسه اجهزه
استخبارات منافسه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اما انه كان من منطلق يعني
احداث بلبله وفرقه عين جوده التعبير
لنفسه كي يشتهر وينتشر عبر الوسائل
الاعلاميه
السؤال يعني مطروح بقوه انه شخص يعني
برتبه منخفضه كهذا الشخص كالشاب جاك يعني
كيف يمكن
ه على تصريح
يمكنه من الاطلاع او الولوج الى اسرار
دوله مثل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
طبعا هناك في الجيش الامريكي وعاده في كل
الوكالات الفيدراليه الامريكيه درجات
مختلفه من
[موسيقى]
ما يسمى بالسكيورتي كليونز او
الحصول على الرخص الامنيه التي تتيح
للموظفين الفيدراليين بمختلف انتماءاتهم
وطبقاتهم الوظيفيه الولوج الى معلومات
سريه وهذه المعلومات ايضا السريه تكون
متدرجه في اهميتها وفي قوتها هذه
يعني
الرخصه المطلقه بالامن اولا تاخذ مده
طويله يعني انا انا كنت حامل لهذه الرخصه
عندما كنت اعمل في الخارجيه الامريكيه
كصحفي وكان هذا هذه الرخصه اخذت مده يعني
حتى تخرج كاستطيع اطلع على معلومات معينه
واستطيع ان امارس مهام عملي بطريقه معينه
فكانت تاخذ مده وهناك رخص امنيه تاخذ مدد
طويله جدا يعني انا رخصتي الامنيه اخذت ما
يخرج من سبعه او ثمانيه اشهر من التحقيقات
والتعقبات والتتبعات الى اخره هناك رخصه
اخرى
ممكن ان تصل
اربع سنوات
[موسيقى]
معينه صحيح
يكون بدرجه عسكريه قليله ولكن ربما يكون
من الخدمات المعاونه لضباط كبار يستطيعون
الدخول الى هذه الاماكن وهو يستطيع ان
يدخل الى هذه الاماكن بحكم انه يعمل معهم
لكن اعتقد التحقيقات هي التي ستكشف
ما حدث مع هذا الشاب وكيف وصل الى هذه
المعلومات وكيف خرج بها اصلا بعد ذلك من
المركز او القاعده العسكريه لان الدخول
والخروج الى القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه
وانا جربت نفسي بهذا الامر كثيرا
هو عمليه محفوفه بالمخاطر اذا كان هناك اي
جرم من الممكن ان يرتكبه اي شخص يعني فكره
ان تخرج ورقه او تدخل بورقه هذا امر خطير
وصعب جدا ان يحدث سيد ايهاب ابقى معي
والان يور تايم ساتحدث بانه المشتبه به
بتسريب وثائق البنداجون قد يواجه تهمه تصل
لعشر سنوات عن كل جرم كان طبعا
شبكه سي ان ان قالت بانه المعتقل في موضوع
الوثائق السريه لديه اراء غير تقليديه
فيما يخص سياسه امريكا اشارت الى انه وضع
قيود على السلاح وكان يحاول لفت انتباه
المنتسبين الى التطبيق الذي نشر عليه
الوثائق او نش رت عليه الوثائق السريه
ينضم الينا اندروبيك نائب كبير الخبراء في
معهد اتلانتي كنسل كانسل للابحاث اهلا بك
سيد اندرو يعني تعليقك بالبدايه عن ما
تقوله سي ان ان بانه لهذا المشتبه به كان
لديه يعني تصرفات او سلوك
قد يوحي بانه ينتمي الى التيار معين او ضد
سياسه البلاد
لو تذكرنا ما حدث بعد حرب
البارده كان هناك براد لمني وهو محلل
استخبارات امريكي كشف عن اسرار هائل بشان
حرب العراق وحرب افغانستان لموقع وهذا ما
جعل هذا الموقع يشتهر على الساحه العالميه
وطبعا كان هناك معارضه للحرب وكذلك
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه من قبل مسرب
هذه الوثائق
اعود اليك سيد ايهاب يعني هل الخوف الان
من انه هذه المعلومات سربت والاكتفاء بها
ام انه ممكن ان يكون هناك معلومات
ربما تم الاحتفاظ بها يعني لم تنشر وبيعه
او اعطيت لجهات خارجيه اخرى
اعتقد التحقيقات ستكشف المزيد من التفاصيل
على هذه الامور
الشاب تم القاء القبض عليه منذ دقائق
معدوده
وبالتالي المعلومات يعني كما سمعت وكما
عرفت من الوسائل الاعلام الامريكيه ان
هناك بعض الاصدقاء لهذا الشاب من خلال
موقع
ديسكورد لتبادل المعلومات وانشاء
المحادثات المختلفه قاموا بهم الاخرين
باخذ كثير من هذه الوثائق وقاموا بتسريبها
في اماكن اخرى يعني لملمه هذه الوثائق
والمعلومات التي انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي اعتقد فتكلف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كثيرا سواء من الجهد او من
المال او من يعني تازم العلاقات مع جهات
مختلفه وحتى تهزم على قد الولايات المتحده
بين الجهات الفيدراليه وبعضها البعض بين
وزاره العدل والفند بين حتى داخل الافرع
الجيش الامريكي لان كم المعلومات التي تم
تسريبها وكم من يقفون خلف هذه المعلومات
وانتاجها وكتابتها وتحليلها الى اخره كل
هؤلاء سيساءلوا لم يفلت من هذه التحقيقات
شخص ما وهذا الشاب سيفتح ابواب جهنم على
كثيرين داخل الولايات المتحده
اعود اليك سيدي اندرويد يعني اليس يعني
قمه الاحراج ان تعرض اسرار الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على منصه العاب بين
مجموعه من المراهقين يعني حتى الان
التحقيقات لم تظهر كم هذه المعلومات وهل
ستستطيع واشنطن لملمه هذه الاسرار
ان هذه الوثائق قد
خسارتها المتحده وحصلت عليها اجهزه اجنبيه
بطبيعه الحال ومن المشاكل المطروحه هو انه
في اعقابي احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر فان
بنيه الاجهزه استخباراتيه الامريكيه التي
تم انشاؤها في عقابي هجمات الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر فان حجم الاشخاص الذين يستطيع
الوصول الى المعلومات السريه زاد بشكل
هائل وهذا شمل اشخاص لديهم الحق في الوصول
الى وثائق غايه في السريه اذا هناك عدد
هائل من الاشخاص يمكن ان يحصلوا على وثائق
غايه في السريه وهم ليس لديهم وسائل يمكن
ان يحموا بهذه الوثائق ويمكن على العكس ان
يسربوها الى اطراف اجنبيه
ابقى معي سيد اندرو وكذلك سيد ايهاب لنذكر
بما اعلن عنه البنتاجون بانه التحقيقات لا
تزال مستمره بشان مسرب الوثائق السريه
وايضا حول ما اثير عبر وسائل الاعلام عن
محتوى تلك الوثائق
الوزير اوستن البنتاجون ياخذ موضوع
تسريبات الوثائق على محمل الجد وصلنا
العمل الاستخباراتي على مدار الساعه لكشف
ملابسات الامر وكيفيه سير التحقيق بشان
المسرب الوثائق السريه وماذا سنتحدث عن
الوثائق المسربه الحساسه على خاصه لا اثير
عبر وسائل الاعلام عن محتوى تلك الوثائق
اعود الى ضيوفي السيد ايهاب عباس وايضا
سيد اندرو وكذلك مراسل العربيه احسنت هل
من جديد حسين
ممكن السؤال نعم هل من جديد هل من معلومات
جديده يعني حتى يعني لانه بالدقائق
الاخيره عم بيكون في تحديثات
نعم بالفعل ما سمعناه بانه نيويورك تايمز
قال بانه قد يتم توجيه تهم الحاق الضرر
الولايات المتحده ولكن حتى الان هو لم يتم
توجيه التهم اليها هنا يجب ان نوضح هذه
المساله حتى الان هو اعتقل ولكن لم توجه
له اي تهمه التهم قد تصل التي قد توجه لها
قد تصل الى عشر سنوات عن كل جرم
قد يتم توجيه التهم له بموجب قانون التجسس
هذا ما لدينا حتى الان من معلومات جديده
تعمل تم الكشف عنها والاعلان عنها ولكن
نذكر بان حتى الان حتى وزير العدل لم يقل
بانه تم توجيه التهم له هناك الان تحليلات
من قبل مسؤولين وخبراء بانه قد يواجه او
توجه له هذه التهم بموجب قانون التجسس
وايضا وقد تصل
هذه سنوات هذه التسريبات
وقع على الشارع الامريكي
هناك حاله استغراب في الحقيقه كما ذكرنا
سابقا هذه التسريبات تاتي بعد عقد من
الزمن على التسريبات التي قام بها او قامت
بها تشيلسي والتي عرفت يومها ايضا بوثائق
وكيليكس وبعد كل الاجراءات التي اتخذت
تاتي اليوم بعد عشر سنوات
ليتم
وقوعها كذا تسريب يعتقد بانه حتى في بنفس
الاسلوب الذي تم به
التسريبات او تمت بها التسريبات الماضيه
بانك كان المجتمع بين موجودا في افغانستان
ولكن لديه القدره على الوصول الى الوثائق
في البانتاجون يعتقد بان جاك تيتشرى كان
موجودا في هو بالفعل وكان موجودا بمثل
وكان لديه القدره على الوصول الى هذه
الوثائق في الباندا في واشنطن هناك حديث
عن هذا الموضوع لذلك هناك حاله استغراب في
الولايات المتحده بكيفيه تكرار هذا
الموضوع مرتين خلال عقد من الزمن رغم كل
هذه الاجراءات والتي اتخذت طبعا لاحظنا
كيف تحدث المتحدث باسم عن كيفيه حمايه
المعلومات في المستقبل يبدو انه محرجا
الان بسبب هذا التسريب ويطمئن ويؤكد على
اتخاذ اجراءات جديده لحمايه المعلومات
السريه ومن من يستطيع الوصول الى هذه
المعلومات وفقا للتصريحات الامنيه التي
لديه هناك حاله من البلبله حسب ما لاحظنا
هناك الكثير من الاراء هذه الاراء طبعا
وهذه الضغوط تتزايد كما قلنا مع
مطالب في الكونغرس الامريكي من اجل اجراء
تحقيقات واجراء عقد جلسات الاستماع
لمسؤوليه
لتقديم اجابات للمشرعين الامريكيين هنا
يجب ان نذكر بان هذا الامور تحدث
والكونغرس في عطله الاسبوع المقبل سيعود
المشرعون الى العاصمه واشنطن وسيكون هناك
الكثير من السجال حول كل ما جرى ومطالب
كثيره للحصول على اجوبه توضح ما جرى وتوضح
ما هي الاجراءات التي ستتخذ في المستقبل
لمنع حدوث هكذا تسريب جديد اعود اليك سيد
ايهاب يعني ذكرت منذ قليل بانه القبض على
المشتبه به سيفتح ابواب جهنم على الكثيرين
التداعيات هذه التسريبات وهذا
الفشل الاستخباري او بحمايه المعلومات اذا
صحه التعبير بحمايه معلومات حساسه لدوله
كبرى مثل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تداعيات ذلك داخليا وكيف يمكن ربط ايضا
ربما لاحقا بالانتخابات الامريكيه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وثقه الشعب بهذه بهذا
النظام
بكل تاكيد كلها تداعيات كبيره في كل
القطاعات التي ذكرتها حضرتك المواطن
الامريكي اليوم
بسبب هذا الموضوع بسبب طبعا موضوعات اخرى
كثيره خلال فتره عامين بحكمه الرئيس
الحالي جو بايدن فقد الثقه في كثير من
الوكالات الفيدراليه الامريكيه سواء كانت
هذه الوكالات الامنيه او تعمل في المجال
الاقتصادي او المجتمع او حتى السياسي
واصبح يفقد الثقه ايضا في نوابه الذين
يختارهم لمجلسي الشيوخ والنواب لا اتحدث
عن فقدان الثقه بالنسبه 100% لا اتحدث عن
كل المواطنين الامريكي لكن اتحدث عن
التيار العام يبدو انه يسير في هذا في هذا
الاتجاه وهذا الاطار الجمهوريون من خلال
هذه الاحداث المتكرره المتعلقه بالامن
القومي الاستراتيجي للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والتي اخطا وفشل فيها
قيادات اداره جو بايدن في التعامل معها
خلال عامين سواء من الانسحاب المزري
والمغذي من افغانستان بالشكل الذي شاهدناه
او الهلال كثير من الملفات المتعلقه
بالقضايا الكبرى على مستوى العالم او
اغفال امن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الداخلي والخارجي ايضا كل هذه الامور تؤدي
الى فرص اكثر للجمهوريين من خلال
الانتخابات القادمه خاصه اذا ما استطاعوا
ان يلعبوا دور المحقق
[موسيقى]
يعني
المتهم
الديمقراطيين بالاهمال من خلال سيطرتهم
على مجلس النواب واعتقد انهم كذلك واعتقد
انهم سينتظروا قليلا جدا من الوقت لكي
تاخذ بعض التحقيقاتها ومن ثم سيتم تشكيل
لجهن لمحاسبه ومعاقبه وادانه طبعا كل
المقصرين الذين هم سيعتقدوا بالفعل
يعتقدون انهم ينتمون لاداره في كل الم
التي ذكرناها بما فيها سيكون هذا الملف
ملف التسريبات لانه الملف الاكبر الحالي
والاني الذي من الممكن ان يؤدي الى خساره
الديمقراطيين الكثير من المكانه التي
اكتسبوها في المجتمع الامريكي
وكما كانت كورونا هي السبب في اخراج
دونالد ترامب من البيت الابيض قبل عامين
ربما تكون هذه التسريبات هي سبب في اخراج
جو بايدن من البيت الابيض بعد اقل من عليه
السيد اندرو هل توافق السيد ايهاب بانه
هذه التسريبات قد تكون السبب في اخراج جو
بايد من البيت الابيض
ولكنني اعتقد ان هناك سيكون انعكاسات
كبيره لهذا التسريب فهذه الحادثه سوف تدعم
خطاب جمهوريين بان رئيس بايدن لم يتمكن من
توحيد الحلفاء الامريكيين لم يستطيع توحيد
الغرب
ورغم كل ما قاله بشان توحيد الحلفاء وان
يكون دبلوماسيين جيدا هذه حجه اذا ضد
المنصه السياسه الخارجيه الاساسيه لرئيس
بايدن ولكنني احذر بان الانتخابات
الرئاسيه لا تزيد على بعد سنه ونصف وهذا
هذه فتره زمنيه طويله في الحياه السياسيه
الامريكيه سيكون فيها الكثير من الامور
ولكن الاثار الكبير اليوم هو ان السياسه
الخارجيه
لبايدن يبدو انها في مازق كبير
يعني تحدثت منذ قليل عن بنيه الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه بعد احداث 11
ايلول وايضا عن حجم الاشخاص الذين لديهم
القدره على الوصول الى معلومات حساسه
بهكذا اختراق كبير مثل تسريب وثائق
البانتاجون من الملام يعني هل الخلل اين
الخلل
بطبيعه الحال من
يتحمل مسؤوليه هي وزاره الدفاع واداره اذا
مكانه هناك اي اختراقات امنيه في نهايه
المطاف المسؤوليه تقع على وزاره الدفاع
والاداره الامريكيه واعتقد انه يجب ان
يكون هناك نظره معمقه بشان رسل الكترونيه
السريه واتوقع ان سبب الذي جعل هذه
الوثائق السريه للغايه تصل الى هذه
المستويات هو انها تم
ارسالها عبر رسائل الكترونيه والوثائق تصل
الى
الحسابات البريد الالكتروني ويتم تحويلها
ايضا الى
الموظفين في المستويات الدنيا اذا حدث ذلك
اعتقد هذا ما جعل هذا الشخص يصل الى هذه
الوثائق الغايه في السريه وادى الى
انتشارها بهذا الشكل
سيد
يعني الضرر بالعلاقات الدبلوماسيه
والسياسيه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
اقرب حلفائها
يعني كل المعلومات التي اتت الى هذه
الوثائق طبعا كل دوله تقوم بتحليلها طبقا
لما توفر لديها من معلومات وستخرج بنتائج
بناء عليها اما تبقي على علاقاتها مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان لم يحدث
اي شيء وهناك دول ربما ستلوم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالطريقه التي فكرت
فيها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في علاقاتها
مع تلك الدوله تحديدا مثلا وكيف ان هناك
بيانات ومعلومات اخفتها اداره عن تلك
الدوله انها دوله حديثه وصديقه مثلا هناك
دول اخرى ستعتبر نفسها انها ربما ستكون
طبقا لهذه البيانات عدوا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في المستقبل او ان واشنطن نفسها
ترسم سيناريو هذا العداء خلال الفتره
المقبله
مع هذه الدوله
يعني اعتقد ان كل دوله على حدا ستاخذ هذه
المعلومات وتنظر اليها وتحللها بالصوره
التي تتوافق مع امها القومي ورويتها
الاستراتيجيه لعلاقتها مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وعلاقتها مع دول العالم
الاخرى بكل تاكيد سيكون هناك ملامات
وعتابات سواء كانت على عالميه او خلف
الابواب
للمسؤولين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
خاصه ربما الذين شاركوا في بناء هذه
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه المسربه
للولايات المتحده في علاقاتها مع كثير من
الدول وربما سيكون الضرر سيقع على دوله
اوكرانيا بشكل كبير جدا ربما على العلاقات
الامريكيه
الاوروبيه ايضا في هذا الاطار المتعلق
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وربما ايضا ستكشف معلومات كثيره لاعداء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الذين ينافسونها في شتى المجالات
يستطيعون بناء على تلك المعلومات ان يبنوا
او يحسنوا او يعدلوا من خططهم
الاستراتيجيه في التعامل مع الولايات
المتحده لان اليوم اصبحت الخطه مكشوفه كما
لو كنا نلعب مباراه كره قدم واتطلع المدير
الفني لاحد الفرق على خطط الفريق الاخر
وكيفيه تعاطيه مع المباراه وشاهد كل شيء
على الورق فعندها سيستطيع ان يتعامل مع
هذا الفريق المنافس وماوضع كل الخطه
البديله للفوز عليك تماما كما يحدث في في
مجال الرياضه وكره القدم من الممكن ان
تحدث في مجال السياسه ولكن هل من خطه
ربما كل هذه التوترات المتعلقه او الملامه
الخفيه او المعلنه بعلاقات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع حلفائها يعني ما
الذي يمكن ان يكون ناجحا
لملمه مثل ما وصفتها منذ قليل ما حصل
نعم ابقى معي السيد ايهاب وايضا سيد اندرو
وكذلك
تداعيات ملف وثائق الفينتاجون المسربه
تتواصل يوما بعد يوم وجديدها تقرير جديد
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه وفقا
للتقرير مسرب الوثائق السريه هو شاب
امريكي قام بمشاركتها مع مجموعه من معارفه
واصدقائه على تطبيق ديسكورد الشعب يحمل
الاسم المستعار او او جي وقال لي زملائي
في المجموعه انه حصل على الوفاء خلال عمله
في قاعده عسكريه لم يحددها وتحدث احد
افراد المجموعه لواشنطن بوست قائله ان
الشاب نشر مئات الرسائل طوال اشهر منها
مقتطفات استخباريه سريه وبحسب الصحيفه قال
اوجي لرفاقه انه نسخ الكثير من تلك
الوثائق باليد لانها موجوده في اماكن
يحضر على اشخاص معينين دخولها وحمل
الهواتف او حتى الاجهزه الالكترونيه كما
كشف عدوان في المجموعه عن انهما يعرفان
الاسم الحقيقي لاوج اضافه للولايه التي
كان يعيش ويعمل فيها لكنهما لم يكشف
المعلومه من جانبها تمكنت صحيفه من الوصول
الى الشخص الذي من المحتمل ان يكون مسرب
الوثائق من خلال ملفه الشخصي الخاص
بالالعاب عبر الانترنت وايضا سجلات اخرى
بحسب المعلومات الاوليه فان جاك تكشيره
تتطابق مواصفاته وعمله مع تفاصيل موجوده
على هوامش بعض صور الوثائق السريه المسربه
الشاب طيار بالحرس الوطني يدير مجموعه تضم
نحو 30 شخصا اكدت والدته للصحيفه ان ابنها
كان يعمل في نوبات ليليه في قاعده كيب كود
في الولايه التي يعيش فيها وانه غير رقمه
رقم هاتفه في الايام القليله الماضيه
[موسيقى]
نذكر مشاهدينا باخر العواجل ان تحدثت بانه
اجراءات الامن المكثفه حول منزل المشتبه
به بتسريب الوثائق هي بسبب خلفيته
العسكريه وكانت ايضا نيويورك تايمز قالت
بانه المشتبه به ستوجه اليه تهم الحاق
الضرر بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبانه قد يواجه عقوبه تصل لعشر
سنوات عن كل الجرم وزير العدل ايضا تحدث
بانه هذا الشاب سيحقق معه في محكمه بوستن
نشاهد اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور وكانت الاف
بي اي اعتقلت مسرب الوفائق وايضا
البنتاجون قيد وصول بعض الافراد للمعلومات
الحساسه
نتابع مع ضيوفنا من جديد مراسل العربيه
حسين الطود ومن واشنطن المحلل السياسي
ايهاب عباس وايضا اندريه كبير الخبراء في
معهد اتلانتيك اهلا بكم جميعا من جديد
السيد اندرو يعني
كيف برايك ستتعامل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحديدا اداره بايدن مع هذه
السقطه الاستخباراتيه
اول ما ستقوم به الاداره هو ان تظهر
استعراض قوي للقوه حتى يرى الجميع ان هناك
انتشار كبير
للقوات الامنيه لان هذه مساله ذات اولويه
للحد من الضرر
السياسي ولكن انه الامر يبعث على السخريه
يعني يتمكن هذا الشاب العامل في الحرس
الجوي الوطني من تسريب هذا الكم الهائل من
الوثائق المسربه وطبعا سوف
يتم محاكمه هذا المشابه به الذي لن يمضي
بقيه حياته في السجن ولكنه سوف يواجه
احكاما بالسجن ثالثا هذا ربما سوف يشمل
ايضا الحق في الوصول الى الوثائق السريه
سوف يتم النظر بع في ترخيص الامنيه وسيتم
اعاده النظر في الاجراءات الامنيه بسبب
هذه التسريب سيد ايهاب يعني كانت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قالت بانه هذه
التسريبات قد تكون معدله وبانه ليست صحيحه
بكاملها يعني بعد كل المعلومات التي توفرت
والتصريحات
ووزير العدل يعني هل تصدق بانها قد تكون
معدله
يعني هناك تسريبات
غير منطقيه في الواقع
وتسير خلف توجهات الاداره الامريكيه بشكل
واضح وصريح وعلاقتها مع عدد من الدول بشكل
واضح وصريح تلك التسريبات المتعلقه بكل من
كوريا الجنوبيه ومصر واسرائيل
يعني اعتقد ان هذه التسريبات ربما بالفعل
يكون تم ادخال تعديلات عليها ربما اقول
وليس ولست متاكدا
لان ربما في نهايه المطاف نعلم ان لعبه
السياسه والحرب هي لعب خادعه وبالتالي من
الممكن ان يتم استغلالها بشكل تبنى عليه
علاقات زائفه
واستراتيجيات من شانها ان تضع هذه
العلاقات في المستقبل على المحك مع عدد من
الدول فربما هذا الامر قائم وربما غير
قائم انا شخصيا اميل لفكره انه ربما يكون
هناك تم بعض التعديلات على هذه الوثائق
لكن اعتقد ان الافضل هو ترك
تاخذ مجروها وبالمناسبه سيكون سهل جدا على
وسائل التحقيق وعلى سواء في وزاره
الامريكيه التاكد من مدى حقيقه اذا ما كان
هناك تلاعب في الوثائق لان اليوم الوثائق
هي موجوده اصلا لدى الولايات المتحده
والوثائق التي تم تسريبها ونشرت على
الانترنت تم تجميعها ومعروفه للجميع
كما
هو وسنعلم كلنا ما هو الزائف وما هو
الحقيقي ابقى معي السيد ايهاب حيث نشرت
نيويورك تايم صوره توضح كيف حصل المحققون
على الادله التي تثبت تورط الشاب في تسريب
الوثائق وكما تظهر الصوره تطابق العينات
من مطبخ المشتبه به حين التقت صورا
للوثائق المسربه نشاهد اذا
هذه الصوره التي نشرت من قبل نيويورك
تايمز
اذا نعيد ان
حصلت على هذه الصوره التي تظهر كيف حصل
المحققون على الادله التي تثبت تورط جاك
تيكي شيرا في تسريب الوثائق وكما تظهر
الصوره تطابق العينات من مطبخ المشتبه حين
التقط صورا للوثائق المسربه
اعود اليك سيد اندرو يعني ما التسريبات
الغير منطقيه برايك من ما سرب والتي قد
تكون معدله
اعتقد ان هناك وثيقه تمت التعديلها وتتعلق
بالضحايا الروس والاوكرانيين اتذكر ان عدد
الضحايا الروس ثم خفضه وعدد الضحايا
الاوكرانيين تم زيادته الانطباع باندا
روسيا على الصعيد العسكري افضل بكثير في
الحرب في اوكرانيا اكثر مما هو عليه الحال
ولكن ليس واضحا في ميداء كان ذلك حقيقيين
لان هذه الوثائق تم نشرها على الانترنت
وعلى قناه تيليجرام ليس واضح انت ما فيه
اذا كانت التعديلات تمت من خلال
المدونين العسكريين الروس الناشطين جدا او
من قبل
الجهاز الاستخبارات او اجهزه الاستخبارات
الروسيه
انتقل الى السيد ايهاب سيد ايهاب يعني
الان كيف يمكن للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان تعيد الثقه يعني تعاملها
وعلاقاتها مع الدول التي وردت في هذه
التسريبات يعني ان تحتفظ بمعلوماتها
السريه هل يستدعي ذلك ربما تغييرات جوهريه
بوزاره العدل ليس وزاره الدفاع اعتذر
يعني بكون حضرتك تقصدي يعني تعديلات في
مناصب
صحيح لا اعتقد لان الاستراتيجيه في نهايه
المطاف العسكريه او
الاستراتيجيه السياسيه الامريكيه هي نتاج
عمل مشترك بين وكالات فيدراليه داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والبيت الابيض
الخارجيه الامريكيه
النواب يعني الكونجرس بالمجلسين نواب
وشيوخ
ومراكز الابحاث السياسيه وخلافه
فتغيير الاشخاص
لا ير ال الاستراتيجيه التي تبني عليها
الولايات المتحده علاقاتها مع الموضوع ليس
فقط علاقاتها او استراتيجيه علاقاتها
الموضوع الان تسريب هو ببنيه ربما هذه
الاستخبارات
يعني تخيلي حضرتك يعني ولنفترض مثلا ان
هذه التسريبات كانت حقيقيه وكانت بناء
يعني تسريبات حقيقيه وما اتى على ذكره في
هذه التسريبات من
امور متعلقه بدول حليفه المتحده الامريكيه
كانت سياسات وضعتها مثلا اداره
ووضعتها الخارجيه الامريكيه كيف سيتم
الاستغناء عن جو بايدن اليوم كيف سيتم
يعني اخراجه من البيت الابيض الا
بانتخابات الامريكيه
مثلا كان على علم مثل هذه التسريبات او
هذه اقصد هنا ما اتت عليه الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه في هذه الوثائق قبل ان تسرب
ولكن علم بعض التحقيقات ان من شارك في وضع
هذه مثلا
الاستراتيجيات الامريكيه هم قيادات كبيره
داخل العالم السياسي الامريكي سواء من
البيت الابيض او من الخارجيه او من
الكونجرس او او هذه
يعني كيف ستغيرين هؤلاء الاشخاص اذا تمت
التضحيه واعني هذه الكلمه تضحيه ببعض
الشخصيات العسكريه او الاستراتيجيه داخل
العمل اروقه العمل السياسي الامريكي
فاعلمي انها مجرد تضحيه لذره الرماد في
العيون لا اكثر لان الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه لا يبنيها شخص واحد بمفرده ولكن
كما قلت لحضرتك مؤسسات كبيره تبني هذه
الاستراتيجيات
ابقى معي سيد ايهاب وكذلك ضيوفي نذكر بما
قلت شبكه سي ان ان المعتقل في موضوع
الوثائق السريه لديه اراء غير تقليديه
فيما يخص سياسه امريكا واشارت الى انه وضع
قيود على السلاح وكان يحاول لفت انتباه
المنتسبين الى التطبيق الذي نشر عليه
الوثائق السريه من جانبها قالت صحيفه ان
المعتقل قد يواجهتها من تصل الى 10 سنوات
عن كل جرم مشيره الى انه ايضا سيواجه تهم
الحاق الضرر بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
من جديد سيد انجرو يعني هل ارتباط هذا
الشاب بجهه خارجيه او عدمه قد يعني يكون
مرتبط بمن الجهه المستفيده
هل هذا احتمال وارد اصلا
بطبيعه الحال وهذا امر اكيد وهذا ليس
بالضروره له صله بشخص مباشره نحن ندرك انه
كان هناك
جهات اجنبيه من اوروبا الشرقيه وكذلك
اعضاء روس حصلوا على هذه الوثائق المسره
هؤلاء قد راوا بان هذه الوثائق كانت مهمه
بالنسبه لهم وتم ارسالها الى الاجهزه
المختصه في روسيا واعتقدوا انه في المدى
القريب فان هذه وسيقت تفيد كثيرا روسيا
والخصوم الاقليميين لاسرائيل
وروسيا وكلى هذا هذه هذين هذين البلدان
يمكن ان يتضرر بسبب هذه الوثائق وهذا يؤدي
طبعا الى الحاق
الضرر بالسرقه بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده
السيد ايهاب يعني نذكر قبل المتابعه باخر
الاخبار اذا نيويورك تايمز تقول بانه
المشتبه به بتسريب وثائق البنك ستوجه اليه
تهام الحاق الضرر بامريكا وبانه سيواجه
يعني عقوبه تصل لعشر سنوات ونحن نشاهد هذه
الصور التي
عرضناها منذ لحظه اعتقال مكتب التحقيقات
للمشتبه به بتسريب وثائق
البانتاجون سيد ايهاب يعني اذا يعني هيك
نظرت الى الصوره من الخارج
منذ بدء تسريب هذه المعلومات الى الان ما
يعني ما الذي يمكن استخلاصه
يعني حضرتك
الدرس المستفاد من هذه التسريبات
في المقام الاول والاساس هو انه يجب ان
يكون هناك امس براني اقوى من ذلك بكثير
للدوله الاكبر والاقوى على مستوى العالم
عسكريا وتجاريا واقتصاديا
لان اليوم مثل هذه التسريبات تضع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
في خانه ضعيفه جدا فيما يتعلق بحمايه
نفسها لنفسها
وهذا
الامر يتطلب جهودا كبيرا واموالا طائله
وهناك اصلا ميزانيات اعتمدت خلال الفتره
الماضيه من قبل الكانجرس للعمل على تعزيز
الامن السيبراني للولايات المتحده لان
الاختراقات السيبرانيه من قبل القراصنه
سواء كانوا من روسيا او من غير روسيا
كثيره جدا
ومتعدده وتطال وكالات فيدراليه كثيره ولكن
حتى اللحظه لا نستطيع او لا تستطيع
الولايات المتحده ان تثبت التهم ضد من
تتهمهم يعني وهذه مشكله ايضا كبيره
فبالتالي يجب اولا الدرس المستفاد ان يكون
هناك تامين بمعنى كلمه تامين سيبراني قوي
جدا لا يمكن اختراقه
ويتفوق على الامن السيبراني لدى الدول
المنافسه او العدو للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا جانب الجانب الاخر ان يكون
هناك ايضا مراجعات
الدوريه وفوريه لكل من يعمل في النظام او
كل من لديه تصريحات امنيه
ولديه
او دخول او ولوج على معلومات مهمه تماس
وطال الامن القومي الامريكي وعندما اقول
الامن القومي الامريكي لا اعني فقط الامن
الاستراتيجي المتعلق بالعسكره او بالسياسه
ولكن كافه المجالات كل معلومه متعلقه باي
مواطن امريكي حتى ولو كان عاطلا ويجلس في
منزله هي معلومه مهمه من الممكن ان
يستغلها ان يستغلها اعداء ومنافسه المتحده
الامريكيه في وضع خطط للضرر بالولايات
المتحده اعتقد هذان هما الامران المهمان
من وجهه نظري
الى مراسلنا حسين قبل ان اشكر كحسان يعني
هل من تصريحات من
الجمهوريين او حتى الديمقراطيين حول
عمليه التسريب هذه
حتى الان لم اسمع اي تصريح من قبل
الجمهوريه ما عدا التصريحات السابقه التي
كانت تتحدث
وتطالب
كما قلنا عقد جلسات استماع لمسؤوليه
والاداره الامريكيه لتقديم معلومات كافيه
للمشرعين الامريكيين حول ولكن بطبيعه
الحال سيكون هناك تصريحات جديده بعد
اعتقال جاك تشاير
ولمعرفه المزيد من التفاصيل حول كيفيه
وصوله الى هذه المعلومات وحدوث خرق جديد
كما قلنا بعد عشر سنوات من الاخر الذي حدث
ابان معلوم وثائق ويكيليكس هذا شيء منتظر
متوقع من قبل المشرعين الامريكيين يمكننا
نتحدث عن جمهوريين والديمقراطيين وكما
قلنا هناك مطالبات منذ الاسبوع الماضي
لعقد جلسات استماع هذه المطالبات وهذه
الضغوط ستتزايد خلال الساعات والايام
القادمه نذكر بان الكونغرس الامريكي هو في
عطله الان الاسبوع المق سيعود المشرعون
الى العاصمه واشنطن ويعود الكونغرس الى
عمليين يمكن نتحدث عن مجلس الشيوخ او مجلس
النواب لذلك هناك حراك سياسي قوي نتوقعه
الاسبوع المقبل من قبل المشرعين الامريكي
لمعرفه المزيد من المعلومات او لاطلاعهم
على المزيد من المعلومات بطبيعه الحال
سيكون هناك جلسات استماع علنيه ولكن
المواضيع الحساسه كما تعودنا ستكون من
خلال ضمن جلسات استماع سريه هذا ما نتوقعه
في الراويه
السيد ايهاب الخبير في الشؤون الامريكيه
سيد ايهاب اهلا بك ايضا بالسيد اندرو
والسيد عقيل عباس ايضا
ينضم الينا في هذه التغطيه سيد عقيل هل
احتمال انه لروسيا يد في هذا
التسريب في هذه الوثائق السريه المسربه
وارد هل يمكن ذلك
يعني ليس منطقيا او معقولا ان روسيا تسرب
مثل هذه الوثائق
واضح انه هو التسريب امريكي يعني ما اعلن
اعتقد يقترب من الحقيقه رغم انه غريب ان
الامر يتكرر بعد ان اتخذ البنتاجون يعني
قبل عشر سنوات في بخصوص ويكيليكس يعني
اتخذ اجراءات صارمه تحدد الى حد كبير عدد
الذين يصلون الى معلومات حساسه من ذوي
الرتب الدنيا
الان يبدو انه شخص ايضا في بدايه
العشرينات من دور رتب الدنيا حصل على هذه
الوثائق يبدو انه طبعها
اخذها خارج المبنى ثم صورها وارسلها في
موقع الكتروني
هناك خلل ما بالتاكيد في
طريقه عملهم خصوصا ان هذه الوثائق بعضها
تصل طاوله الرئيس رئيس الولايات المتحده
علينا ان ننتظر ونرى ما الذي سيرشح من
التحقيقات لكن واضح انه هذا فشل فشل كبير
روسيا قد يتصورون ان هذه التسريبات
وراءها محاوله تظليل بمعنها انها ليست
تسريبات حقيقيه الغرض منها تضليل الروس
قبل شان الهجوم الاوكراني يعني هذه واحده
من الاحتمالات لانه يبدو غير قابل للتصديق
انه هو شخص جندي
في مستوى واط يعني في القانونيه الامريكيه
يستطيع الحصول على هذا العدد الكبير من
الوثائق ذات المعلومات الحساسه
ويبعثها علينا ان ننتظر ونرى ما الذي
سينتج من هذه التحقيق ساعود اليك سيد عقيل
بهذه النقطه ولكن نشرك السيد اندروبي
بموضوع روسيا ضيفنا
السيد عقيل يعني يستبعد ان يكون لروسيا يد
في هذه التسريبات
اعتقد ان روسيا ربما لديها دور في نشر هذه
الوثائق المسربه بعد ان نشرها هذا المشتبه
به الى مجموعته ووصولها الى قناه تيليجرام
اتوقع ان يكون هناك ربما بعض عملاء
الاستخبارات الروسيه الذين عملوا على
النشر هذه الوثائق النطاق اوس ولكن مره
اخرى ربما هذا قد يكون له صله بافراد
متعاطفين مع الجيش الروسي وهاهم الذين
قاموا بتسريب هذه الوثائق عن نطاق
الجزيره لك
دكتور للابحاث
وسيد ايهاب عباس يعني
هناك يعني جهه تستبعد ان يكون تكون روسيا
منخرطه في هذه التسريبات وراي اخر يقول
بانه قد تكون ساهمت بنشرها نشر هذه
التسريبات والترويج لها مع اي راي انت
وربما يكون الروس قد جنده هذا الجندي
الامريكي
لاحداث هذه التسريبات وربما جندوا غيره
ورب يعني المساله مفتوحه على كافه
الاحتمالات لكن توقعاتي الشخصيه
هي ان هذه التسريبات جاءت بمحض الصدفه
كعمل فردي من هذا الشخص
وروسيا يعني حتى اللحظه لم يكن لها اي
تعليقات على هذه التسريبات سواء بالسلب او
بالايجاب بل ان
السيد
[موسيقى]
المتحدث باسم الكريم قال ان روسيا تدرس
هذه الوثائق لمعرفه مدى
حقيقتها ومدد جديتها فبالتالي الامور
مفتوحه على كافه
يعني تستثمرها روسيا
بكل تاكيد هي معلومات مفيده جدا لروسيا
خاصه اذا كانت متعلقه بخطط حربيه
لاوكرانيا على المستويين القريب والبعيد
النوعيات الاسلحه متى تصل كيف تصل وكل هذه
الامور التي تسعى روسيا بكل تاكيد
للحصول عليها
وبالتالي تاتي اليها على طبق من ذهب يعني
ستستفيد منها بشكل كبير
وستؤدي طبعا في نهايه المطاف ايضا الى
تغير
ربما في السياسيات والاستراتيجيات والخطط
من قبل اوكرانيا ومن قبل الولايات المتحده
والغرب لان عمليه التسريب بكل تاكيد ستكون
لديها يعني في المقابل الروسي استعدادات
جيده وخطب بديله لما تراه اليوم بام عينها
من خلال هذه الوثائق
كل الامور مفتوحه على كافه الاحتمالات
وكافه التعاملات
لكن
من وجهه نظري في هذا الامر حتى اللحظه ان
روسيا تبدو ليست لديها علاقه بهذه
التسريبات خاصه وان
هذه التسريبات تقول ايضا ان روسيا مخترقه
من الداخل يعني روسيا تقول
التسريبات تقول ان روسيا
اخترقت في اجهزتها الامنيه والاستخباراتيه
من قبل وكالات الاستخبارات الامريكيه
وبالتالي هذه معلومات غير مصلحه روسيا
وهناك معلومات اخرى في غير مصلحه روسيا
اتفق مع مقاله الضيف من واشنطن السيد
اندرو على ما اعتقد فيه ان ربما يكون تم
تعديل بعض الارقام المتعلقه بضحايا هنا
وهناك لكن ليست هذه هي القضيه الاساسيه
القضيه الاساسيه هي الخطط المستقبليه
متعلقه بالحرب على ارض الميدان وكيف ستؤثر
هذه الخطط سواء بالسلب او بالايجاب على
التعديل
ربما الان يعني من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او حتى اوكرانيا
طبعا ولذلك سمعنا ان اوكرانيا ازالت هجوم
الربيع وقالت سنقوم به
القسم هذه اول نتائج هذه التسريبات
ولكن سيكون هناك ضرر يعني مئه في المئه
سيكون هناك ضاره لان ما لدى روسيا اليوم
من خر
ائط على التحركات الاوكرانيه على الارض
والاستراتيجيات التي كانت مرسومه خلال
اشهر قادمه هذا سيعطي روسيا ما يسمى
بالادفانتيج او فرصه التقدم ان تكون دائما
سابقه بخطوه خلال الفتره القادمه وحتى يتم
تعديل هذه الخطط وبدايه تنفيذها وتطبيقها
من جديد ستكون فقط كثير من المكاسب
ميدانيه وطبعا على المستويين العسكري
والاستراتيجي همم نعم اذا شكرا جزيلا لك
السيد ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي حدثتنا
من واشنطن
وانتقل الى السيد عقيل لدي دقيقه واحده
قبل ان انتقل الى الزميل صهيب يعني انت
ذكرت بانه ليس من مصلحه روسيا ان تسرب هذه
المعلومات ولكن اذا دخلنا بالتفاصيل هنالك
عده نقاط قد تكون او قد يمكن ان تستغلها
روسيا منها ما سرب بانه هناك عدد صغير من
القوات الخاصه قوات خاصه غربيه عامله داخل
اوكرانيا
والمملكه المتحده يعني اكثر عناصرها هي من
المملكه المتحده واللي هي يمكن ربما ان
تستغلها روسيا لاحقا بانه
بريطانيا هي عضو في الناتو وتشارك في هذه
العمليه العسكريه من داخل اوكرانيا
وبهذا يعني يعطيها حقوقا عده كرت فعل
روسيا
يعني ان صح هذا طبعا كل الذي نقوله ان صحت
يعني بانتظار التحقيقات بطبيعه الحال ولكن
نتحدث عن التكهنات والسيناريوهات
روسيا تخسر كثيرا اذا كان لديها مثل هذه
المعلومات التفصيليه ولا تستغلها على ارض
الميدان وتختار بدلا من ذلك ان تسربها من
اجل ان تحرج بريطانيا او امريكا في هذا
التفصيل او ذاك التفصيل اعتقد ان بهذه
الطريقه هي تخسر كثيرا لانها كشفت
للغربيين للامريكيين والبريطانيين انها
قادره لان تصل على مثل هذه المعلومات
الحساسه الطرف الاخر سيغير من طريقه تواصل
كي يمنعها من الوصول لهذه المعلومات ما
فائدتها ان تمارس ضغطا اعلاميا ضد
الولايات المتحده او ضغطا سياسيا ضد
بريطانيا اعتقد مثل هذه الامكانيه
غير مجديه لانه يعني الخارطه العالميه
الغرب اقوى بكثير اعلاميا اقوى بكثير
سياسيا في هذا النزاع فما الجدوى من
التضحيه
بامكانيه هائله الوصول للمعلومات
الامريكيه الخاصه من اجل احراج امريكا
وبريطانيا من دون الحصول على فائده عمليه
على الارض في ساحه القتال شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد عقيل ستبقى معنا في هذه التغطيه
وانتقل الى زميلنا صهيب شراير لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات